there's such a buzz going on about nfts  those crazy little pieces of digital art  for example trading for millions of  dollars everybody's excited about it but  here's the truth i think the biggest  opportunities in nfts are tied to  physical assets let me give you an  example watches now watches grow in  value as they get older in other words  if you buy a watch from a company like  patek philippe and it becomes vintage  it's worth way more than what you bought  it for but you don't know if you're  buying a fake watch when you buy a  vintage watch so an nft can become the  certificate of authentication  that's what the big potential is that's  a space that i'm investing in because i  know the watch world and i'm one of  those infected watch collectors i want  my own collection to have nfts for every  single watch have them insured and have  them approved by the manufacturer that's  the potential and that's just one use  nfts are going to be  huge